trouble with zoom and
yeah thanks for thanks for waiting
so um maybe we should get get started
right away so this is the last
colloquium for this year
um
and we are ending on a on a high note
with uh with a terrific colloquium and a
great panel
so i'm i'm really pleased to uh
uh
to uh introduce uh robert huang
from caltech he's he's
he's um
he's jointly advised by john prescott
and uh and thomas vedic
and he's done um
really foundational work on classical
shadows and on
on how to use these in in learning
algorithms and
you know to get around this data
bottleneck
so really looking forward to your talk
robert uh
would you be able to share your screen
now
yeah
[Music]
okay then should i just start
yeah my name is robert and
for today's quantum colloquium i'll be
talking about making predictions in the
quantum world i will cover a series of
work in collaborations with richard kuhn
john prescott steve lamia jordan cutler
ceton chen jerry lee michael broughton
and jerry maclin
so one of the central goals of in many
disciplines of many scientific
discipline is to learn how the physical
world operates
here we consider learning as a
combination of receiving processing
storing information
such that subsequently you can use the
store information to make prediction
about the future of the physical world
and how one should engineer it to
provide certain
benefits
so previously classical learning theory
have provided a lot of the foundations
for understanding how an asian could
learn about classical functions
classical distribution etc
however the physical world that we live
in is intrinsically quantum so it's very
important to understand um the
generation of classical learning theory
to learning about quantum states quantum
processes and so on so here in this talk
i would cover some of the recent
progress in developing a theory for
learning about a quantum mechanical
world
the outline for today's talk is as
follows i will separate the talk into
three parts the first part we talked
about learning with a classical agent on
understanding what's the power of
classical asian what can they learn what
can not learn and so on
and in the second part of the talk i
will dive into talking about learning
with a consummation and discuss what
kind of quantum advantage could we
obtain over classical agent
finally i would present experimental
demonstration of the quantum advantage
achieved by quantum agents on the
sycamore processor
so let's begin with the first part of
the
talk
so here we will consider a classical
agent which is an abstract model for
scientists um an experimentalist or even
classical machine learning algorithm etc
where this classical agent can interact
with a physical world that's operating
quantum mechanically
the classical agent could conduct
experiments by providing some
instruction for how one experiment
should perform and obtain experimental
outcome from the physical system in
order to learn about the physical system
so let's begin by defining what one
experiment is so this is just a formal
definition one could tweak it around
with the definition but here is one
general form of definition that one
could use
so here we would consider classical
agent to specify some action so these
are
controls that the parameters that
control the physical system by the
classical agent
um more generally we consider this form
of having first perform x followed by y1
to yl and finish with z
so
what what this xyz meant will 12v become
clear
very soon
so the instruction would be provided
to the physical system to conduct one
such experiment
and what the physical system would do is
depending on what this axis the physical
system will prepare
a quantum state rho x which represents a
quantum many body system this quantum
system could be very very complicated
for example one could consider this
input x to represent
some hamiltonian of a many body system
and this row x corresponds to the ground
state of such a hamiltonian let's say h
of x
so but it could be also very simple form
like for example um the x just
corresponds to rho x just corresponds to
preparing the all zero state so this is
just a general framework for
for preparing the state which is
parametrized by this input x
and then in the next step the physical
system will evolve the system will
evolve the state the drill x under some
quantum many body dynamics which is
represented by a cptp map ey1 which is a
general representation for all possible
quantum dynamics not just unitary
dynamics but also
some stochastic dynamics and so on
so this evolution will be specified by
the second
action of the classical agent so y1
corresponds to
the evolution that we perform and and
follow up on that um
depending on what y2 is the physical
system will then evolve the state under
um a second evolution ey2
and
the physical system would just go to do
the evolution
up until effyl
and now the state
prepared in the physical system is shown
above
and at the end what we would do is we
would perform
what the consequent agent would do is
it will perform a measurement on the
physical system represented by a povm mz
which collapses the state and produces a
measurement outcome for the classical
agent
the classical agent could conduct
multiple experiments
for example
he could start with some instruction for
one such experiment
obtain the measurement outcome depending
on the measurement outcome design a
second set of experiments obtain it
again and do that and repeat this
process for multiple rounds
um
so this is a very general and not this
is a very abstract model for
essentially all possible kinds of
experiments one could perform in
in physical sciences such as in quantum
experiments or even in chemical
experiments or in other kind of
experiments
and
depending on the situation um
changing some of the parameter might be
easy or hard like for example maybe
changing x is pretty difficult um but
changing z like what is the basis that
one measures um is much more easier
however we're just going to throw away
all of that detail and just focus on
this abstract form um to
to discuss um what kind of classical
agent learn about the physical system
so
so yeah so one of the key questions that
we would like to understand is through
this interaction with the physical
system what can the classical agent
learn can they learn what's the state
being prepared can you learn what's real
x okay learn what's ey or can learn
what's mz
or can it learn to predict properties
about the saving prepared and so on
so
before diving into some of the content i
would like to review some of the results
discussed in john prescott's talk at a
previous quantum colloquium held at
april 27th which illustrates some of the
predictive power of a classic classical
agent
so in john's talk he has presented this
classical shadow formalism which is a
procedure that we proposed last year
in this classical shadow formalism we
assume that some of the evolutions are
known and one of the measurements is
known so basically when the classical
agents specify an action y that's in
clifford group the associated evolution
ey shown here is we assume that is the
ideal cliff per unitary on the other
hand if the classical agent said perform
z equal to zero then the measurement m0
corresponds to the ideal computational
basis measure so that's the key
assumption used in classical shadow
formalism when one treat in this more
general framework basically what
classical shadow formalism tells us is
that given any x
that's such that this row of x is
unknown the classical agent can perform
very few amount of experiments to
predict many properties of this unknown
quantum say row x using this proposed
classical shadow formulas
building on classical shadow formulas
and one can perform a
a great variety of different quantum
many body problems for example
one could consider using classical ml
combined with classical shadow formalism
to classify
various quantum phases of matter
including spt phase topologically older
phase and so on basically in this recent
work published around half a year ago we
showed that one could train the
classical agent such that given a new x
corresponding to some unknown rho x the
classical agent can perform a polynomial
number of experiments
here polynomial in the system size to
accurately predict the quantum phase of
rho x
so here we again we're utilizing the
same assumption as classical shadow
formalism we're assuming that some of
the evolutions are known and one of the
measurements correspond to m0 is is
known and it's the ideal computational
basis measurement
another application of classical shadow
formalism that illustrate the power of
classical asian is for predicting ground
states
here we go back to one of the example
that i mentioned we consider row x to be
the ground state of some gap hamiltonian
h of x living in some finite spatial
dimension that's parameterized by this
m-dimensional vector x living in some
hyperkey
in this paper we proved that after
performing a polynomial number of
experiments polynomial in this m and
independent of system size the classical
agent can efficiently learn to predict
the ground state properties of this
hamiltonian h of x for any x in this
hypercube in this m-dimensional
hypercube to a constant average error
again here we're utilizing the same
assumption as classical shadow
formalities
so as you can see some of these
applications classifying quantum phases
predicting ground states are
often being
said as the application of quantum
machine learning algorithm but here you
can see that using a classical agent um
interacting with the physical system
plus a classical machine learning model
one could achieve these tech to some
degree so like for example it's constant
average error and there are some
restrictions on what kind of quantum
phases of matter one could um predict
however the key take-home message from
john's talk or from these previous
results is that classical asians are
really quite powerful at learning about
quantum systems and solving quantum many
body problems
especially when some of the evolutions
and measurements are perfectly known
like in the assumption of classical
shadow we assume that this clifford
group is known clifford unitary is known
and the computational basis measurement
is also perfectly known
however it raises the following very
natural question
what if none of the states none of the
evolution and none of the measurements
in the physical system are perfectly
known
can the classical agent still
achieve its original power or
can it still learn certain things that
are useful or things just breaks down
so
this is a pretty tricky question and
quite apart um so in order to better
understand um what the classical agent
can learn under this more general
situation where nothing is no nothing is
known we have to first provide some
formal definition so the first
definition that i would consider is it's
called world model so the word model
basically just specifies the physical
description of each action for example
when the classical agent said do x what
is the actual quantum say relax that's
being prepared when i say do y what is
the actual evolution ey and so on so
formally a world model is just a
collection of this mapping from the
action x y z to the corresponding
physical operation rho x e y and m z
so
in physical reality the classical agent
will live in some role model which we
call the true world model however the
classical agent doesn't know what this
true role model is but he or she has a
set of candidate role models which is
denoted as a model class q which is just
a set of all possible candidate role
models including the true role model
and what the classical agent tries to do
is he would try to learn what this true
world model is among the candidates in
this model class queue
and we say this model class which is
just a set of all candidate role models
is learnable if whenever the true world
model lives in this if it's inside this
queue the classical agent can learn all
the physical operation in the true world
model so here we do know that it's up to
a global unitary or anti-unitarian
transformation which is intrinsic in
quantum mechanics so so discussed in
this theorem known as the wickner
theorem
there's this degree of freedom in
quantum mechanics that one could choose
freely so
again here we're going to consider
classical asian learning the physical
operations up to this global unitary or
mt unitary transformation
so so that's a very quick summary of the
definition
for this test and now we could try to
understand what is learnable what kind
of situation is learnable for classical
asian and what are not learnable
so we will begin by providing
a sequence of examples demonstrating
what are situations that's unlearnable
from starting from the simplest one
shown here so here we consider a model
class consisting of two role models
canada world models a and candidate
where models b essentially what the
classical agent tried to do is to
understand if it's living in world model
a or world model b
so in this situation we consider a very
simple qubit system with only four
actions um the first action prepares
some state the other two action
in the world model a evolves the state
under hadamard gate
and the phase gate and finally the last
action which corresponds to a
measurement performs a perfect
computational basis measurement
in world model v however um the two
evolution actions becomes
too noisy and it's now just producing a
completely mixed state no matter what
state you're putting in
so as you can see the two world models
are
physically like they describe physically
different reality um in particular for
people well-versed in gay-set tomography
these two world models are not related
by a gauge transformation
however
it's impossible for the classical agent
to distinguish between the two world
models because the states in both cases
is a complete mixed state so no matter
what experiments so recall that one
experiment means a sequence of x y one y
two y three finishing with z no matter
what experiments the classical agent
performs
the resulting outcome is going to be a
uniform distribution and that's why the
constant agent will not be able to
distinguish between the two world models
so this is just a very trivial example
of a situation that's unlearnable
however one could consider a less
trivial example that's still unlearnable
so in this situation we consider having
again two world models where they both
prepare a perfect perfect zero state
can perform a perfect computational
basis measurement can implement the
phase skate perfectly but for the
hadamard gate it will be subject to some
noise
so for world model a it's after applying
hadamard gate there's a small chance an
epsilon probability of having a bit flip
error x error happening on the state
on the other hand in world model b there
is a small chance of having a face
this is a pretty usual scenario that
people often consider
there are some
incoherent noise happening in the device
and we just wanted to figure out which
is which whether it's more likely to
have bit flip error or facebook error so
then we can tune our device to better
combat these kind of errors
so now
basically we're going to show is that
these two world models are again
indistinguishable they're unlearnable
it's impossible to for the classical
asian to figure out if it's in world
model a or word model b
to get a better understanding for why
that's the case let's consider a very
specific experiment so let's say we
start from x equal to zero
let's say the class equation instructs
the physical system to perform x equals
zero which prepares this
perfect zero state and now let's say the
classical agent conducts a hadamard gate
after so in world model a because
bitfib error actually leaves plus state
on change so after this action the state
in role model a it's just plus state on
the other hand for a world model b it
will be a different state because there
are different physical realities
however when the constant agent performs
a second petamar gate then suddenly the
two states in the world models become
the same
basically for world model b
p z will now act
as an identity but p x would actually
change the state to become this mixed
state
so since the state and two row models
are the same when we perform a perfect
computational basis measurement we're
just going to see the same output
distribution zero was probability one
minus epsilon and one with probability
epsilon
so as you can see at least for this
experiment it's impossible for the
classical agent to determine if it's in
world model a or where model b
however using
some proof technique one could show that
for all possible experiments that the
classical agent could do the output
distribution is going to be the same in
world model a and b and that's why the
classical asian is never able to learn
which physical reality you are sure it
is actually in
and the situation is actually even worse
um even if we add in another gate the t
gate and we assume that it's just a
perfect t gate so now
in world model a one could perform
perfect t gate in both world models one
can perform perfectly gate
even with this universal gate set
hedamar phasegade and t-gate the
classical agent is still unable to learn
whether it's in world model a or where
model b using a similar proof technique
this could even be further generalized
so the situation is even more
uh challenging in a sense that even if
the constitution can approximately
prepare any state any quantum state um
again apply tk perfectly have the market
perfectly and apply any clifford gate up
to a polynoise so polynoise is just a
probability distribution over having
some x error y error or z error
and again you can perform computational
basis measurement perfectly so now in
this setting there is an infinite number
of actions that the classical agent
could perform
but it still cannot decide whether for
the hadamard gate whether a biff error
happened or a phase flip error happen
so this result can be condensed into the
following theorem stating that
gate-dependent polynomials meaning that
the
noise for each gate whether it's and
assuming that it's a polynomial it's
unlearnable in physical systems in
quantum systems with
noisy clifford gates and perfect t-gates
under spam errors
so it's important to note that
um there have already been a lot of
works on
like learning quantum processes learning
quantum states
oftentimes people assume that let's say
the state preparation and the
measurement are perfect and so on in
those kind of settings people can learn
the quantum process using just clifford
gates however as one could see when
everything has some noise and everything
is unknown learning becomes very very
challenging um
and it's
pretty likely that we will encounter
these kind of unlearnable situation and
so on
so given these results one would ask
then are there even situations that it's
actually learnable is is it true that
actually all situations are unlearnable
or
or actually there are some classes of
models where we can actually learn
things
in order to answer this question
in order to make progress on answering
this question we present the following
theorem we showed that given a model
class which is just a set of candidate
world models such that for every
candidate role models w there exists an
unknown actions that repairs the
piercing we don't know what the unknown
action is we don't know what the
piercing is but just guarantee that it
prepares a pure state and some unknown
actions that form a universal set of
unitaries again we don't know what those
actions are and finally there is an
unknown action that performs a povm with
a povn element not proportional to
identity so the last condition basically
just means that
the povm is non-trivial in a sense that
when given a povm such that all the povm
elements are proportional to identity no
matter what state it is the povm is just
going to produce the same distribution
so it's going to be completely useless
here we just need to assume that there
is one such povam such that it's
slightly non-trivial it's not completely
trivial then we can show that
every role model inside this model class
for any role model in this world model
class in this
model class we can the classical agent
can learn all the physical operation so
basically at the starting point the
classical asian would just have all
these different actions x1 x2 y1 y2 y3
and so on that corresponds all of these
different states
evolutions and measurements that are
completely unknown to the classical
agent however by doing experiments the
classical agent can actually learn all
of them
so now in order to better understand the
theorem let me provide a very brief
proof sketch of this theorem
so the first step that the classical
agent could do is perform a unitary test
basically using the fact that unitary is
the only reversible physical process one
could the classical agent could identify
what are the evolutions that are
actually unitary dynamics so let's say
the classical agent identified these
three evolutions as unitary dynamics
now what the classification could do is
he can combine these things randomly
composed and randomly to produce a hard
random unitary standpoint
so the basic idea here is that a random
composition of a universal set of
unitaries actually approach to design
and even further heart measure so that's
a very important criteria that we're
going to utilize and here's a short
animation to just showcase basically we
just the constitution can just collect
the actions that forms unitary evolution
and then just randomly compose them in
some way and then one could prove that
by doing random composition it would
actually implement a random unitary
sample approximately from the unitary to
design
so note that the classical agent still
has no knowledge of what's the composed
evolution
he doesn't know what's individually what
they are it doesn't know after
composition what they are you just note
that this unknown evolution is
guaranteed to be sampled approximately
from unitary 2 design
so for those that are not familiar with
unitary 2 design basically it's a it's a
definition that considers whether the
unitaries are uniformly spread across
the space of the
special unitary group
so now by just doing random composition
on the unitary evolution one could
generate this
tool called the heart sampler that can
generate
random e that's random evolution e that
corresponds to a random quantum
evolution
so now with this fire sampler where it
would generate some unknown random
unitary and some unknown povm
mz as long as it's non-trivial we can
actually
utilize them to get a state overlap so
we don't know what these higher random
sampling are we don't know what to say
these guys are we don't know what row
are we can still estimate the overlap
between row x 2 and row x
as follows
so basically what we do is we generate a
random evolution from the heart sampler
apply it onto some state measure it
using some unknown povm and then do the
same for row x3 for the other state that
we care about and then follow these
follow through this process for all
possible for different kinds of random
evolution that's been generated by this
heart sampler e1 e2 e3 and so on
basically one could utilize heart
integration formula to show that
the data connected collected this way
actually enables us to estimate the
inner product
between any two quantum state here is
row x2 and row x3 without knowing any of
the evolution any of the measurements
and any of the quantum states
so now we have
built up this overlap estimator
which can then be used to for step four
so in step four what we're going to do
is we're going to what the classical
agent should do is to compose these
different states and evolution to form
all kinds of state such that
it finds a set of states that satisfy a
certain geometry using the overlap
estimator so basically it's a it's a
list of constraints some rigid
constraint that tells us that um for the
inner product between these two pairs
what should it be and so on so it's kind
of a long list and that's shown on the
right hand side but using that list of
rigid constrain
rigid geometric constraint one can show
that it fixes the states that's being
found basically one could prove that
using this special geometry
the the special set of states that's
found must be of this particular form so
some of them are the bases some of them
are superposition of two of the bases
and some of them are the superposition
of three of the bases these kind of
triplet states are actually very
important in the proof because they
the the rigid constraint enabled by
these triplets allows one to pass
information like pass the relative phase
information for a different pair of ij
so that's a pretty
important part
so finally given this special set of
states and the overlap estimator that we
constructed in step 3 we can actually do
quantum state tomography to learn all
the states we can then do quantum
process tomography to learn all the
processes and finally do quantum
measurement tomography to learn all the
quantum measurements so that's a very
short
discussion on how one could prove the
theorem which showcased how a classical
agent could start from
having no knowledge about all the
physical operation to having all the
knowledge about the physical operation
however this is only one such sufficient
condition where
the model that where the classical agent
could learn the role model
understanding
when and what kind of model class a
classical agents can or cannot learn and
how powerful are they under this
situation still remain to be a very
important open questions and it would be
nice if there are much more results
known in this domain
so that concludes my first part of the
talk which discusses some of the power
in classical asian and how it could
build up knowledge from having nothing
by knowing nothing from knowing nothing
about the physical system
in the second part of the talk i would
dive into talking about learning the
world using a quantum agent and
discusses what kind of advantage could
quantum asian brings and over
classical
so recall that so far we have been
talking about classical asian which can
be thought of as
an abstract model representing what
scientists currently do in the lab so
scientists could perform physical
measurements to receive classical
information about the physical system
can process that classical information
using classical computer and storing
that classical information in a
classical memory
however as quantum technology advances
one would begin to wonder what
a quantum future experiments could be
like so this is also very closely
related to
one of the previous quantum colloquium
by dori daronov about quantum
algorithmic measurements which is also
providing a framework for understanding
what an advantage good quantum
technology brings to performing physical
experiments so here what we consider is
a quantification that could receive
quantum information using quantum sensor
processing that quantum information
using quantum computer and storing the
quantum information using quantum memory
a natural question would be what are the
advantage of having a quantum agent that
could interact coherently with the
system over classical asian that only
interact
incoherently classically with the
classical system
understanding this question will
enable will guide us towards
understanding how quantum technology
could fundamentally alter our ability to
learn about the physical world
so in order to
start diving into this question i would
like to simplify the setting a little
bit so previously i talked about
classical asian interacting with the
physical systems with unknown states
unknown evolution unknown measurements
and so on but here that's focus on a
simplified version where the only
unknown the physical system is some
incubus state row so
the physical system generates this
prepares this quantum state row where
the classical agent can learn about this
drill by performing some measurement on
each row for each experiment on the
other hand the quantum agent can obtain
a copy of raw coherently from each
experiment
some more
so here's just a visualization for
illustrating the setting um the
classical agent would have some
classical memory where by performing one
measurement on row we obtain some
classical data that can be stored in
classical memory
another measurement
provide a different set of classical bit
strings which can then be used to
perform classical post-processing
on the other hand for quantum asian what
it could do is
we could take in row and
throw it in its quantum memory taking
another copy of row store it in its
quantum memory and then perform an
entangled quantum data processing on
this collection of quantum data and then
and then finally
implement a measurement to provide some
classical prediction
so now in order to understand um
what advantage could one have over the
other let's consider the following task
so in this task we consider the
consequence and quantum agent to
to be a um two so the consequent quantum
agent should learn a classical model
of this quantum state rule such that
subsequently one can utilize this
classical model to predict a large
number or just some property of the
quantum zero so for example here we
focus on the setting where we want to
predict the magnitude of the expectation
value of some observable p chosen from
this set so such an observable is also
known as the unqubit paladi operator or
pally observable
and one could prove the following
theorem which is shown in this paper
that would come up in
two days
we can prove that a classical agent
actually needs an exponential number of
experiments in order to predict just one
observable chosen from the set however a
quantum agent actually only need
a linear number of experiments to
predict all the exponentially many
observables all four to the end of them
so yeah so there's this exponential
separation between what a classical
agent could do and what a quantum agent
could do so in order to better
understand the theorem let me provide
also again a brief oh there's one side
note that i want to mention is that this
exponential quant advantage is present
even when
the state row
is just a classical distribution over
product
it doesn't need to have any quantum
entanglement in this state this in this
unknown state rule in order for this
exponential advantage to be present
which is a nice feature and
potentially hints as the possibility of
using quantum technology in situations
that are much more classical than we
think
so now let's provide a proof sketch for
how one can establish this exponential
lower bound for a classical agent
for the upper bound this linear upper
bound on quantum asian we're essentially
using a similar technique that's already
been discussed in our previous paper
published in um
january 2021
called information theory bounce on
quantum advantage in machine learning
so in order to prove this classical
lower balance in order to improve this
lower bound we need to
understand sort of the dynamics of the
classical agent in particular let us
consider
a graphical note
representation for the memory state of
the classical agent so here this r
corresponds to
the root of this tree which also
corresponds to
the starting point of the memory state
of the classical agent
every time the classical agent performs
one experiment the memory state would
change like for example depending on the
outcome it might change to this point
this point or this point and then so on
so in the second experiment it would
change other points
so note that whenever two memory state
would go into the same memory state
due to some experimental outcome it
means the information is lost so it
means that the classical agent have
forgotten something so
in order to consider an optimal
classical asian this should never happen
and when this doesn't happen one could
easily show that the graphical
representation of the dynamics of the
memory state must be a tree
so
essentially we start from this root
start branching outward and after let's
say t rounds of experiments this would
be a tree of depth t where there's our
leaf nulls at the end corresponding to
the final memory state of the classical
agent
in order to understand how well
classical asian could learn about the
underlying state
we just have to look at this tree
representation so suppose the underlying
state is row a
then
it would change the sort of the
transition probability from one point to
another for example in row a it's more
likely to go through this transition but
for row b the three transitions are both
equally likely
and basically what one could do is one
could just trace over to this tree and
look at the bottom the leaf probability
distribution so what is the probability
of the final memory state of the class
equation we need that the probability
distribution between the two different
underlying states to be sufficiently
different in order for the classical
agent to be able to distinguish between
the two physical reality
so that's a key technique that we are
going to use later
so now in order to prove the lower bound
for this prediction task what we would
do is we were going to reduce it to a
distinguishing task more precisely it's
a partially revealed many versus one
distinguishing task
so the reason for this partially
revealed is that recall that in this
task what we could consider is um
the concept of asian would first do the
learning after learning we will reveal
some incubate observable p
um
that's revealed and what the agent has
to do is to predict the expectation
value of p on this unknown state row
so suppose that
the revealed observable is pa in this
case we can actually set up the problem
such that
um under that condition the unknown
state is going to be one of these three
choices either a complete mixed state or
this i plus 0.95 pa or i minus 0.95 pa
so these two states are both
just separable states they're classical
probability distribution over product
states so there's no entanglement in any
of these three states and basically when
the constant agent can efficiently
predict the expectation value of
actually the absolute value of the
expectation value that is trace of pa
roll then the classical agent could
efficiently distinguish between this
null hypothesis because here the
expectation value would be zero well
here the absolute value of the
expectation would be 0.95
so
when the classical agent could perform
the prediction test you will be able to
distinguish between the null hypothesis
or the alternative hypothesis
on the other hand if the revealed
information if the revealed observable
is pb we can set it up so that the
underlying state is slightly different
and again
if one could achieve the prediction task
he could achieve the distinguishing task
and now as we discussed before in order
to be able to distinguish between two
situation the leave probability
distribution must be sufficiently
different
meaning that if the classical agent
could succeed in the partially revealed
many versus one distinguishing task then
it yells a lower bound on the total
variation distance and the probability
over the leaf number and then what we
would do which is also some of the core
technical difficulty is to upper bound
the total variation distance with a
function of the number of experiments so
as the number of experiments increases
the total variation distance would also
start to increase
because they can become more different
however one could show that the
relation between them is very very mild
in the sense that we really need to
increase the number of experiments
significantly in order to see a
substantial difference in the total
variation distance and that's how we
establish this exponential lower bound
for classical agents on the other hand
as i said before the upper bound for
quantum agent is already shown in our
previous work
so using similar proof technique one
could also establish quantum advantage
in a wide variety of tasks for example
performing quantum pca
so in this task the agent the goal of
the agent is to learn a fixed property
of the principal component that is the
largest eigenvector
called psi of the unknown state row
here we consider the fixed property to
be a very simple property to be the
expectation value of the polyz operator
on the first cube
using similar technique we can improve
the following theorem we can show that a
classical agent needs an exponential
number of experiments to learn this
property about the principal component
but a quantum agent only needs a
constant number of experiments to learn
this property
so for people that are well-versed in
these literature on de-quantization
one might be
confused and thought wait but isn't even
times already
shown a polynomial time classical
algorithm that could perform quantum pca
doesn't this contradict this fear
so
the resolution is the following so in
human time's result she assumed that
there is this oracle which is called
sample and query oracle sqrco or sqxis
and
the algorithm must be given that access
given that oracle in order to achieve
this polynomial time
computation time however one could
easily shown that constructing sq oracle
from quantum states actually requires an
exponential number of experiments and
that's why
there's no contradiction happening here
the advantage doesn't only hold for
learning physical states it also hosts
for learning physical dynamics where one
could consider a similar situation
comparing classical agents and quantum
asian
particular one could show the following
given a polynomial time physical process
e represented as a cptv map acting on
unqubits
a classical agent requires an
exponential number of experiments to
learn a model of e that can predict
output states accurately on average
however a quantum agent only needs a
polynomial number of experiments in
order to achieve the same guarantee
so
so yeah so that's a series of results
telling us how a quantum asian could be
much much more powerful than classical
asian
in the final part of my talk i would
like to dive into
this experimental demonstration on the
sigmoid processor
for the first set of experiments we
consider quantum advantage in learning
about a physical state
here after learning an unknown state
role we present the agent with two
un-cubic paly operators q1 q2 and the
agent has to predict which one of them
has a larger magnitude in expectation
value
and in figure b we showcase the sigma
processor
so in order to run this quantum
learning algorithm what we do is we
consider this red one as
an additional quantum memory of the
quantum agent where it can store an
additional copy of the state role and
can perform an entangled measurement to
obtain
more information
and furthermore in this experiment we
consider a hybrid quantum learning agent
so basically what we do is we have
quantum agent doing the experiments what
it does is it stores two copy of the
state in its quantum memory and then
perform an entangled measurement to get
some output data we repeat that
processes for end times using a total of
two end copies of row and then feed that
classical data into a gated recurrent
neural network where the gated recurrent
neural network will then predict
which of the two poly operators have a
larger absolute value
and these are the results shown so in
figure b we consider a train the
training process of this hybrid quantum
learning agent
we train this hybrid learning agent on
noiseless simulation data mostly in
particularly this gated recurring
urinary part on noiseless simulation
data for small system size n where n
equals to two three four five six
and then predict on noisy experimental
data obtained from the sigma processor
so the blue line shown here is the decay
of training loss as the training
progresses here we consider a
cross-entropy loss and this purple line
shown here is the prediction accuracy of
the hybrid quantum learning agent
so the higher the better it's basically
1.0 means perfect prediction and 0.5 is
equal to random guessing
we also showcase the prediction accuracy
for the classical agent so here we're
using a best-known classical asian which
corresponds to
utilizing this classical shadow
formalism in order to make the
prediction
we can see that the prediction accuracy
of the best known classical agent is
only slightly above 0.5
where 0.5 is equal to random guessing
in frequency we consider the sample
complexity we consider the number of
experiments required to achieve a good
prediction accuracy
here we consider prediction accuracy of
70
that is for 70 of the time the agent can
accurately predict which one has the
larger magnitude
the crosses the gray crosses shown here
are the sample complexity for the
classical agent
so in order to achieve 70 of the
of prediction error the number of
experiments required by classical agent
as you can see scales exponentially and
um even
so the cutoff here like why do we cut it
only at eight is because for ten the
number of measurements is too high and
we just couldn't
get enough data before like the the
device is not
working anymore
on the other hand we also present this
rigorous lower bound which can be proven
using similar proof technique to show
that the least number of
measurements these number of experiments
required by a classical agent to achieve
this task so as one could see this
scales exponentially in system size
and finally this purple line shows the
simple complexity for using this trained
hybrid quantum learning agent and as you
can see at system size of only 20 we can
already see a huge difference between
the rigorous lower bound which means the
best classical algorithm that could
possibly be conceived
versus quantum agents
so in the
in the next experiments what we consider
is the quantum advantage in learning
about physical dynamics so here is kind
of a slightly different setting we
consider a collection of many different
physical dynamics half of which are
general unitary dynamics and half of the
other which
are dynamics that satisfy time reversal
symmetry which means that when written
as a matrix these
evolutions this unitary u corresponds to
an orthogonal metrics
so starting from dory oharanov and
jordan cutler and xiaolongchi's work on
quantum algorithmic measurements they
consider a restricted
site restricted class of classical asian
and showed that
for those slightly restricted version of
classical asian it requires an
exponential number of experiments to
distinguish between the two and then
follow on
following on top of that in this recent
paper
published at um
2021 we also extended to show that for
all possible classical asian
the number of required experiments
also scales exponentially
when one used classical agent
and for this task what we consider is we
would train an unsupervised machine
learning model to try to uncover this
underlying symmetry structure that is
the
agent doesn't know what physical
dynamics are general what physical
dynamics are to reversal symmetric
it's just being presented with this
collection of different physical
dynamics many of them and then it has to
figure out what are the underlying
symmetry
in figure a we showcased the setting
so for the quantum agent what i could do
is you could coherently access this
physical dynamics it would prepare some
initial quantum memory
feed half of the quantum memory into the
physical dynamics
get the output state coherently do some
quantum processing feed the half of the
quantity
quantum memory into the dynamics again
do some quantum processing and make a
prediction
on the other hand the classical agent
will prepare some initial state
instructed by some classical bistring
evolve the initial state and perform a
measurement to obtain classical data
in both situations we consider a
thousand access to these unknown
physical dynamics
for each of the unknown dynamics we have
a thousand access to it
and we consider a total of 100 different
physical dynamics
and essentially all the collected data
for different k e1 e2 e3 to e10 for
example here we would pass in through
on service machine learning model here
we consider a gaussian kernel pca to
learn a one-dimensional representation
for all the dynamics
and the results are shown in figure b
and c
in particular here we consider both a 1d
dynamics as well as a 2d dynamics
implemented on the sycamore processor
the 1d dynamics is shown like this this
light blue line while the 2d dynamics is
this
2d grid
this white thing is a qubit that's dead
and the results is shown in bnc as one
could clearly see when one used quantum
asian followed by an unsurvised
classical machine learning algorithm um
one could the classical agent the
machine learning model can accurately
identify the two
physical dynamics on the other hand when
one uses classical agent the results the
1d representation is very mixed and
there's no clear separation on any
pattern in this representation found by
the ml model
so now to conclude
um
some
these theories of work have shown that
classical asians are actually quite
powerful in making predictions in the
quantum realm as we said it can
accurately predict quantum phases of
matter it can accurately learn to
predict ground state property and so on
however the boundary of their power
still remains to be exploring especially
when all the physical operations are not
known perfectly
at the same time
our results are also shown that quantum
agents can actually
be
extremely more powerful than classical
agents
this is in stark contrast to most of the
existing results on quantum sensing
which only provides a quadratic
advantage
and due to this very significant
advantage um
in our demonstration on the sycamore
processor we can show that the
significant advantage in learning
ability can still be evident using noisy
intermediate scale quantum technology
and that's it for my talk thank you so
much for listening
thanks a lot robert
that's really great
um let's let's see if there are any
questions from the audience
uh andre are you
do you
yeah there are a couple of questions
that came up now so maybe i'll read one
of them um
says are the resource budgets so for
example the measurements similar for the
quantum and classical agents for the
practical results on the sycamore
processor uh i guess um
he's probably asking about what is the
the say the depths of the measurements
or things like that um
so in both of these cases that we
consider due to the complexity of the
dynamics alone um
we're actually considering measurements
that are only like constant depth
so in both quantum asian and the
classical agent so the classical agent
is a constant depth measurement
the quantum agent is also a constant
depth measurement
so in a sense i think the answer is yes
they're similar um
we're not comparing like quantum asian
having
a significantly deeper
circuit but the classical agent only has
constant but actually both of them were
have only have a constant depth
quantum circuit that's being applied
all right
so it seems like sin one has a question
i think one can you unmute yourself
[Music]
maybe not
um
okay so um
so
possibly while we have while we are
trying to sort that out um we can
we can start setting up the panel uh
panel video so if robert if you could
stop sharing your
your slides
uh
sorry
nice there are interesting questions on
the question and answers
okay
uh
there's a question
amazing work and lucidly presented well
done the examples of unlearnable
settings seem to indicate that even a
little bit of irreducib
irreproductibility in experiments
renders learning impossible what does
this say about the scientific method in
the real world
oh that's a very big question
i'm not sure
yeah so for the examples that i gave
there are literally settings where
it's just impossible to distinguish so
i guess when you really do science in
those kind of regime you're just not
going to figure out that underlying
process like for example um maybe one of
them has dark matter and while the other
doesn't have it but there's no ways to
distinguish them so that could happen um
i don't think the current scientific
methods that people are using are
actually wrong in any sense it's just
there are situations where they are just
impossible to learn so
i don't think it undermines the
scientific method or
it's yeah but that's a very very
interesting question
i think soon
robert can i maybe add something to your
response
uh which is that if you follow the proof
through
um then what comes out is the reason
it's unlearnable is the existence of a
certain noise floor
and so you can quantify that that
presents you it prevents you from
learning
to arbitrary precision
so i think there's a sort of um chicken
and egg game that you can play where you
can uh exchange epsilons and deltas a
little bit and say well if i want more
precision then i just need to increase
i need to you know change delta to be
delta over two and now i can move
epsilon down a little further and vice
versa so i think that it doesn't
undermine the credibility of the
scientific enterprise it just means that
in order to get more precise and
reliable answers you're going to have to
sharpen the questions that you ask in
the apparatus which does the probing and
as long as you continue to
ask sequences of questions
that can converge to the other theorem
that robert presented
which allows you in some limit
to look at unitary dynamics and pure
states then things should be learnable
okay so may i ask you a question sorry
for like uh for the technical problems
well thank you very much for the
inspiring talk robert my question is
most of the examples you talked about is
dealing with either quantum state or
quantum process
so it's in some sense intrinsic quantum
problem because the input is quantum but
the answer is a call do you think there
could be some separations for the
intrinsic clash club problems the
optimization problem or completely
classical settings but using quantum
algorithm
yeah that's that's a great question i
think a lot of the panelists here are
have thoughts deeply about this question
i think at the moment it seems like um
it's still very unclear
like there are results by
by many people showing that the
advantage is at most this and some of
that
so
um
i think it's possible to have advantage
but exponential ones i'm not that sure
well there are the results of about the
welded trees and the recursive simon's
uh quest problem that basically do show
an exponential separation when do you
say robert
yeah but in the sense those are also
quantum oracles right so you you access
them as kind of like a quantum way um so
in a sense it's still kind of quantum um
it's because of the oracle nature like
we're comparing a classical oracle
versus when you have a quantum access to
it
but
so those are yeah but so i'm not
entirely sure if that would actually
happen in
in practical study and even in those
cases like those examples you still have
to have coherent access to these
processes in order to get the advantage
if i
yeah
yeah right but
yeah you're comparing a classical oracle
to a classical oracle when the access to
it is is coherent access right right
right right but i guess someone is more
thinking about the setting where the
axis is all classical like it's complete
classical axis and
whether we can still have advantage in
those kind of settings um because i
guess if we want to access some problem
with quantum axis then in in effect that
oracle or that process itself must still
be some quantum mechanical process so
that you can access it quantum
mechanically right
um if it's completely polarizing then
um like if it depo like if it decoheres
everything
then we're not going to gain this
coherent access to like the simon oracle
or if it's like welded tree oracles and
so on
and speaking of that
relate to this at some point you
mentioned that this separation happens
only for the also for the without
entanglement
yeah but but that does not imply that
you can apply for the classical settings
like what makes it quantum in that
context ah so in that context
there are still quantum systems in the
sense that they're quantum particles
they're like atoms um
they
they're not entangled um there are some
classical correlation between them but
they're completely untangled so
it might it sounded a bit like classical
but it's still not quite in the sense
that they're still quantum particles and
it's because of the underlying
uncertainty principle at play and that's
why you have
quantum advantage it's because
there are uncertainty principles when
you interact with it classically like
when you do measurement on top of it but
when you can store multiple copies of
them in a quantum memory and do like
quantum data processing you can avoid
these kind of uncertainty principle and
that's sort of the root of the cause of
disadvantage so i wouldn't say they're
intrinsic classically i think intrinsic
classical must be like the data is
completely just bit strings and looking
at that data using classical agent
versus quantum nation can yell the
separation for those kind of tests i
think the most well known is schwarz
algorithm but other than that it still
seems a little bit like we have
polynomials speed up but for exponential
ones it's
less clear at the moment thank you
[Music]
okay great um well thanks um so shall we
um if we can get the the
videos of um
of all the panelists pinned up
[Music]
and let me
let me start by